we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this is so
funny this is Troy York again okay Troy
York is a guy who called he doesn't like
the show but oftentimes to try to make
it seem as though his views are more
widely represented in our audience he
calls with fake names once it was like a
Hispanic character I think named Luis
Gonzales or something like that
he's called with a number of different
names I think this is the first time
he's using this new identity
Cecil Brewster and he and Cecil Cecil
Brewster wants a couple of countries
added to Trump's travel ban was take a
listen to Cecil aka just Troy York tapes
game packages Cecil Brewster I enjoy you
so you are wonderful human being just
wondering Trump love travel plane travel
banned it went through sprite all your
nonsense
big news and mentioning of relies in
courts state courts and yadda yadda
yadda yadda yeah Chris Trump plan will
never go through I was just wondering in
on their six little Eastern nations I'm
a travel ban and can they possibly be
extended the internationals plan of two
more nations this being one Argentina
and the other one Israel both of those
countries we put on the travel ban just
if no other reason than just sticking up
the S of one David H segment right okay
good
put the I have no middle name I don't
know what David H Pakman is but yes
there is Troy on Ansari Cecil Brewster
calling in with his views about the
travel ban and he wants Argentina and
Israel added to the travel ban list he's
talking about this as if we were lawyers
are chewing against the travel ban at
the end of the Supreme Court but he
misunderstands what even happened
yesterday like I said the Supreme Court
hasn't said that the travel ban is
constitutional illegal what they've said
is they are backing out of the
preliminary injunction on
some aspects of the travel ban but I
think we're getting into a little bit
too detailed territory for old Cecil
we've got a great bonus show for you
today including what is arguably the
most Boston story ever that we've done
on the David Pakman show
save one that I can think of david
pakman.com slash membership don't miss
today's bonus show it's a good one
sign up get instant access